كان هناك الكثير من الجدل في العام الماضي
حول حرية التعبير ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ،
يجب أن نخطئ في جانب التعبير الأكبر ،
فهم حرفياً
يقرأون الأكاذيب فقط ، ولن تتمكن
شركات الدعاية المضللة التي تشارك في
الرقابة أو أي سلوك سياسي
من الحفاظ على
درع مسؤوليتها  المعضلة التي يجب أن تفرضها شركات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي على
الخطاب الذي
يتسم بالكراهية أو العنف أو الكاذب أو يجب
أن تحافظ عليه بروح
حرية التعبير وما يحدث عندما
يكون المتحدث مسؤولاً منتخبًا أعتقد
أن لدينا مسؤوليتين
لإزالة المحتوى  عندما يمكن أن يسبب
خطرًا حقيقيًا بأكبر قدر ممكن من الفعالية
والقتال من أجل دعم أوسع
تعريف لحرية التعبير قدر الإمكان
بالطبع ، لا ينطبق التعديل الأول
قانونًا على Facebook أو Twitter
أو Instagram أو YouTube ، فقد تمت
كتابته  فقط من أجل منع الحكومة
وليس الشركات الخاصة من فرض الرقابة على
الخطاب ، اشتد الجدل بسبب منشور
واحد محدد  om الرئيس
دونالد ترامب عندما بدأ النهب
يبدأ إطلاق النار ، وضع Twitter ملصق تحذير
على التغريدة يقول إنه يمجد
العنف ، لم يفعل Facebook شيئًا يمكنك
قوله إنك جميعًا من أجل حرية التعبير ولكنك
تحتاج أيضًا إلى حماية المجتمع
خاصة عندما تكون في
سيقول الموقف الذي يمثله فيسبوك في مارك زوكربيرج إنه يؤيد
مبدأ ديمقراطيًا
وهو حرية
التعبير ويقول إنك تعرف أن شركة خاصة
مثله هو ملياردير
حتى تتمكن من معرفة
تقييد الكلام بطريقة ما  من
رئيس الولايات المتحدة ، هل تشتري هذه
الحجة ، لا أعتقد أن هذه
الحجة هي بالكامل مصلحة أرباح مارك زوكربيرج
، أعتقد أن ما
نراه هو أن مارك زوكربيرج يقول أنك
تعلم أنني لا أريد أن أفعل ذلك  لا أريد
إثارة حفيظة الرئيس ، فأنا لا أريد أن
أدعو إلى اتخاذ إجراء تنظيمي. لا أريد أن أتخلص
من أتباع الرئيس
الذي يستخدم أيضًا Facebook
وأنت تعلم أنني لا أريد تنفير
من منصتي الخاصة لأن ذلك
سيقلل من عائداتي ومشاركتي بمفردي ،
لكن أولئك الذين يجادلون بأن Facebook يجب أن
يعمل بروح حرية التعبير يقولون
إنه منحدر زلق لإزالة أو
حتى التحقق من صحة
الخطاب السياسي ، أين سترسم
سطر إذا كنت تستخدم Facebook عندما يتعلق
الأمر بمنشور رابحة ، لذلك أعتقد أن Facebook
Corden خارج نطاقين
ضيقين للغاية من الحكمة إغلاقهما ،
وهذه أشياء مثل الكلام المضلل
حول الانتخابات نفسها إذا نشر ترامب ،
مرحباً ، الجميع يصوتون على
يوم الانتخابات في هذا التاريخ وكان التاريخ خاطئًا
أعتقد أنه من المعقول
إزالته لأنه جاء في الوقت المناسب وأيضًا
مضلل بشكل واضح لأشياء مثل
خطاب الكراهية.أعتقد أن الناس يجب أن
يعرفوا ما إذا كان الرئيس يستخدم
خطاب الكراهية فأنت لا تعتقد ذلك
يجب أن يقوم Facebook بالتحقق من صحة الإعلانات السياسية.
لا أثق في أن Facebook يقوم بعمل جيد
- التحقق من صحة الإعلانات السياسية.
الكثير منها صحيح ولكن المضللة
هذه هي الفئات التي
يحتاجها الشعب الأمريكي لسماع
نقاش كامل حول فكرة عدم وجود مارك
زوكربيرج حول ما يجب أن
يدور حوله النقاش ولكن في الواقع الكثير من
الجدل الفلسفي حول الحرية  من
الكلام ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي كانت مجرد
فلسفية في الممارسة العملية ،
فقد قام Facebook بإزالة المنشورات السياسية التي
أزالها إعلانًا تم تشغيله بواسطة حملة ترامب.
من الأشياء طوال ذلك الوقت ،
والآن فجأة ، هناك
مشكلة لماذا يحدث ذلك بشكل جيد وتسمع
تحيزًا متحفظًا ولكنه في الواقع ليس
تحيزًا متحفظًا ، لقد قاموا
بإزالة نفس النوع من خطاب الكراهية منذ عام
2008 2009 وهناك المزيد  من هذا
النوع من خطاب الكراهية ، فإن خطاب
ترامب وحزبه قد أصبحا
وكأنهما قد غيرا فجأة
القواعد التي يجب أن تكون متحيزة ضد
المحافظين أعتقد أن الأشخاص الذين
يعتقدون حقًا أنك تعرف
أن الشركة يجب ألا تتدخل بأي شكل من الأشكال في أي
شيء
يقوله السياسي بغض النظر عن مدى الاعتراض ،
هل تعتقد
أن هناك حجة هناك  حجة صحيحة
مفادها أن نعم إذا كنت أنت مارك زوكربيرج ،
فمن المنطقي أن تقول ذلك ، إذا
بدأت في الإشراف على المحتوى ، فسأقوم
بدعوة مناقشة حول
الشروط التنظيمية التي تتعلق بشركتي
بشأن الإشراف على المحتوى وأنني سأفعل
ذلك  قل حسنًا ، دعنا نرحب بذلك
لأنني أعتقد أن
الوقت قد حان لإجراء مناقشة مفتوحة
حول ما هو صحيح في هذا المجتمع
وما هو الخطأ خاصةً عندما يكون
لدينا بيئة وسائط قذرة وصاخبة
بفضل Facebook في منشور
مدونة  قال Facebook إن مسؤولية
التحقق من صحة الإعلانات السياسية لا ينبغي
تركها للشركات الخاصة ، حيث يكتب
فيسبوك والشركات الأخرى في وقت أقرب
للمساءلة الديمقراطية.
القواعد الخاصة بهذا الأمر كان ذلك أفضل ولكن في
غضون ذلك قبل انتخابات 2020 ،
أعلن موقع فيسبوك أنه يسمح للمستخدمين
بإلغاء الاشتراك في الإعلانات السياسية لبعض
النقاد على الرغم من أن السؤال يبقى
هل هذا كافٍ